MODERATOR: Now we are recording now i'm going to give you remote control, could you try to please move the mouse around.
P7: The mice.
P7: No.
P7: You can't control to have to take control automatic or two after.
MODERATOR: Okay now.
P7: Is there was just too late okay.
MODERATOR: Okay, so yeah keep in mind there's gonna be a delay.
MODERATOR: And whenever you feel you're ready, you can start the.
MODERATOR: timer.
P7: Should I read this in advance.
P7: is fine.
MODERATOR: No it's it's part of the first task so.
P7: Okay, please go ahead.
MODERATOR: Okay i'm something in now.
P7: Just reading the instructions are the homepage.
P7: Okay, so it hides the complexity.
P7: The dashboards hiding the complexity and quite curious what that means okay.
P7: yeah that's i'm not quite sure I got been one of the things that hiding the complexity okay and.
P7: instructions to use the dashboard or look very straightforward.
P7: and
P7: And perhaps if I was wanting those three steps I would put it in kind of bold keywords.
P7: And and those three points, just to kind of.
P7: highlight them, perhaps.
P7: So the inputs pretty.
P7: Clear.
P7: Yes, and information around what what what the data on profess to data yeah, I suppose, like data and data point density and those kind of almost footnotes some degree i'm quite.
P7: yeah it's the first time, the word data no data comes open health data researchers book The words just yeah it's it's an interest, like the information just appears data and data point density, but.
P7: OK, but and it doesn't really linked to the the kahan information around the.
P7: Well yeah.
P7: Clinical very rare disease data Okay, and just wondering like winners referral reference to data.
P7: Those two points whites and I guessing like on whether pollution or aerosol it takes you to a descriptor yeah okay.
P7: or no it doesn't does it.
P7: just highlighted those three a delay.
P7: And then open up okay i'm.
P7: curious, but the comparative cab I should go there now.
MODERATOR: It will come later.
P7: Okay, so okay i'm clear known this the cell home.
P7: So I want to apply their how to use dashboard steps.
MODERATOR: You might be missing task one the last step.
P7: is sorry or ever put it away.
P7: On.
P7: Hidden document apologies.
P7: warehouse my chat.
P7: i'm.
P7: Sorry.
P7: I think I have a like I have a lag.
P7: Ah, sorry i'm controlling.
P7: that's not.
MODERATOR: I can stop.
P7: For a moment yes.
MODERATOR: yeah, what do you need to do is you need to click in another window in your computer or otherwise they cannot.
MODERATOR: Stop the remote.
P7: And so i'm I know on another window.
P7: You stop sorry with this.
MODERATOR: No, no, I stopped the timer so it's fine okay so.
P7: I just need to get.
MODERATOR: A stop the remote control.
P7: yeah just need to get to the.
P7: let's get the instructions for me again.
P7: Most of.
P7: The screen say.
P7: Okay sorry.
P7: there.
P7: We can take control back possible.
MODERATOR: All yours.
P7: just going to read.
P7: he's going to control i'm just gonna revisit those steps again.
P7: Okay, so yeah i'm ready to open open up.
Okay.
P7: This few.
P7: Oh sorry that was me was it and.
P7: Okay, so I want to make a query and, as I move down with me he knows i'm leaving time with me.
P7: So the left hand menu is not moving down as I can just observe that map we don't know if that makes an impact just yet.
P7: And I will, I suppose, because i'm submitting a query.
P7: So I can have maybe it's me, but I wanted to see the map, but I guess it's not because the disease is the first.
P7: selectors element it doesn't have any respect that relationship to the map and maybe location of interest, though I was scrolling down.
P7: And yeah ideally, I would like to.
P7: Have that and.
MODERATOR: And the men explaining me the map.
P7: map looks like it breakfast bread broken down currently on county by county.
P7: Excluding Northern Ireland which.
P7: yeah okay and.
P7: Popular is a population density data point density.
P7: not sure what data oh sorry.
P7: Number of data points yeah well.
P7: Whether pollution aerosol okay and.
P7: When it's a combination of weather pollution and aerosol as data and not sure if I see the benefits of highlighting Dublin has a very high.
P7: density of points as opposed to Cork Waterford male seem to have a different shade on.
P7: My my light here.
P7: For your mixing three different types of weather pollution, air assault and.
P7: unusual it's an unusual metric.
P7: Okay, in that in.
P7: to distinguish it by.
P7: This my current thought actually on that okay.
MODERATOR: Do you mind opening with a mouse over the map.
yeah.
P7: Court pollution seven weather fourth density 11 yes Okay, so the information is is available when you hover but.
P7: I don't know if I would always have, however, on the.
P7: yeah I know the answer is true the instructions highlight hover over the regions but.
P7: Putting weather and putting those two things together.
P7: Okay, and i'm not seeing the benefit.
P7: and
P7: If anything, I would prefer to see two side by side with them individually.
Okay.
P7: yeah.
P7: In terms of metrics they're not something that.
P7: go together.
P7: In my, in my view.
P7: So uh yet the value of this currently it's not something i'm sure.
P7: is necessary.
P7: Basically, sorry if I missed that one.
P7: Okay, so query.
P7: So 1.2910 case or if I.
P7: jumped there i'm just getting into that process and submit a query using the inputs yeah and.
P7: you're selecting please explain yeah so let's go through that started.
P7: To make choices new ones become available okay okay.
P7: So let's begin ballad.
P7: Q on is displayed to a new expecting a new tab.
P7: Okay, one query only so.
P7: i'm.
P7: So I started tonight give I give vasculitis was the only option available.
P7: Not a problem event of interest, a flare high probability possible no I think i'm most interested in high probability this point.
P7: Is there such.
P7: cases and no event, I suppose, would be on i'm curious about understanding what.
P7: No means are possible means, as well, more maybe more important because that's something that turns slightly in between.
P7: And so now okay there's a new indoor.
P7: event of interest dates So these are.
P7: i'm guessing Lol is location of interest.
P7: really is just location.
P7: And ev give end date I suppose.
P7: A.
P7: shorthand and okay it's in year month day sensible approach because it's easier to search.
P7: Under seven tabs of that okay.
P7: So there's a lot of whoa okay so for Dublin it jumped to quite a large page, as opposed to the others, so it actually forces the page up and down.
P7: Okay.
P7: So it's in County alphabetical order.
P7: Quite a lot of cases.
P7: So i'm six I can select a county know I know I can't separate county I can look just at the number of cases in each county and the timeframes.
P7: So it's just kind of gives me an insight but it's not very select, so I am going to choose, Dublin, because it was quite a lot of cases and might just be interesting to look up.
P7: and
P7: I must return to the I need to return to check the date range for Dublin.
P7: And I can I can select more than one county location of interest.
P7: And can I Tony call Okay, so this offers an opportunity to pick county by county.
P7: Okay.
P7: Or, I can choose Ireland as a whole or Republic of Ireland, I guess, well it's fine and.
P7: yeah I wonder, would it be beneficial if that was actually the map that I could click on the counties they're.
P7: Just like the location of interest.
P7: From the perspective of trying to go through this one by one, because the MIC drop menu disappears every time you slide one.
P7: So i'm sorry Cork it's gone, I have to go again and the good thing is, I noticed that they don't they don't remain in the in the in the selection so that's good okay.
P7: So i'm going to choose iron and actually just I can't choose Ireland I can't okay there's just a delay.
P7: But now the three remain and I don't know if all the others have been added it's sort of like a.
P7: i'm not quite sure, and I have.
P7: Three feature twice or something but anyway we'll go.
P7: and
P7: Looking at Dublin things happened from 2001 2019 I think i'm only going to be interested in 22,009 team, although it was mentioned that only 2020 data was available so so i'm putting cases of know.
P7: So is there any 29 yeah well, is there any 2020 cases, then I will go with that because.
P7: i'm taking all of Ireland, so it doesn't matter.
P7: So okay.
P7: And maybe i'll just pick a period of time actually.
P7: john moved for me there and so now it's from first of August so yeah so the second half of 2020 so it shows that I can pick a period more easily data sources weather and pollution, where there's out automatically take.
P7: For some reason i'm not sure pollution is not take.
P7: Which i'm not sure why that.
P7: option is taken one is not correct or is that something that's accidental.
MODERATOR: You clicked one.
yeah.
P7: yeah I think I think I might have okay that's good to know so and then temple units.
P7: Early daily monthly yearly.
P7: Based on my understanding, you coined early resolutions might be to course also i'm not sure if they feel guilty of the data a daily read out already resolution daily I think would be.
P7: Fine, and I am going to keep it relatively simple with mean.
P7: spatial temporal and aggregation actually no i'm going to choose Max.
P7: Because that might be a more of a trigger.
P7: You can't choose more than one so it's really singular approach, which is fine.
P7: And i'm at that stage where I can click submit so i'm just finishing step two.
MODERATOR: I think I think you can click swimming.
MODERATOR: yeah.
P7: I am.
P7: So the page on the right class disappeared or no it's loading okay.
P7: And are the information that was already there so and for q1 top so i'm reading circuitry while waiting.
P7: and
P7: This takes.
P7: weeks.
MODERATOR: Because you selected all the data for all Ireland.
P7: Should this take.
MODERATOR: it's it's it's already done.
P7: OK.
P7: OK OK so i'm going to explore this and in order to understand the table, there are two buttons so before I go there i'm going to.
P7: floor these two buttons which are meant to give me some information open query input and the open color table description so.
P7: Firstly, the open query input summary I clicked it.
P7: Can you page.
P7: Know hasn't taken mentioned the page, as it is expand.
P7: So it's called something different it's not deep open query and put summary it's called the query and put summary know the table that's intentional and.
P7: rare disease asking so it's it seems like it's a summary of what I select in some key things I select in the menu are previously, which is still visible to me on the left, so it is kind of repeating information and.
P7: it's working period so yeah this information, seems to be a repetition of what i've selected here, and that is still visible so.
P7: it's kind of presenting the same thing, but in a new location in a more condensed table Okay, and just just like no difference in name from open and open and then the open color moving on to the second one and.
P7: A subsequent table so that actually the first table is still open, I can close that can I yes and data background of data normally dispute.
P7: should be plus or minus plus two said scores yes okay and white, so the background will change if not guessing if it was described greater than to read.
P7: Less than two blue.
P7: Okay.
P7: So I think.
P7: What does it mean if it is greater than two versus less than minus two and why would read distinguish from blue.
P7: i'm really not on it for a Friday, but.
P7: What ends yeah but i'm just trying to think is it is it required that this needs to distinguish is this red need to be distinguished from blue or should they both be a fine or red because they are both.
P7: Outside the two two Sigma.
P7: and on VOD significance does minus two and greater than to have and.
P7: Yes, i'll have to look at the results to see what what that means, and so that's the to their accounting load yeah and know that in order again this is called Table colors it's slightly different, you know that not just.
P7: bicycles, is my point my question in the back of my mind, so now.
P7: read the text and the data so so okay so as the text particular interpretation, the variables cell background colors yes, can I got going there already and so data, the full name of the variables.
P7: appear when hovering over the headings of the tables OK so i'm going to do that just a.
P7: lag.
MODERATOR: You need to click on the zoom window.
P7: Yes, yes precipitation Am I okay millimeters OK, so the units really represent that in when you drop you really need to go and.
P7: To go right to know what okay and.
P7: Further information versus data source links in the home tab okay yeah.
P7: Suppose how do I go to the home tab from here, if I wanted to would be my query.
P7: yeah you can tap back there so that's Okay, and I wouldn't would be easy if that was home tab was hyperlinked just to make life easy.
P7: and
P7: toggle columns.
P7: it's like the columns interest okay.
P7: Export.
P7: button to download data csv yeah useful, and only the visible columns will be done only visible and if visible based and once Tyler that's that's Okay, so you have noticed there's red and there's blue and I noticed there seven pages, but I don't think i'm going to call beyond.
P7: The seven pages.
P7: And quite a lot of columns a lot of columns here and.
P7: And i'm going to run through them quickly.
P7: yeah the year month day seems to have an annotation of tea after it, which i'm not sure.
P7: Of angst T ran.
P7: yeah.
P7: yeah precipitation.
P7: temperature.
P7: degrees Christmas together as greasy from memory for knows can get air temperature.
P7: wet Gilbert tennent creature so there's a slight difference between the two, I always use our hitch relative humidity.
P7: As are haters more common in noted percentage vapor pressure.
P7: Pressure so it was quite a lot of.
P7: sunshine hours okay.
P7: Yes, and these are based on.
P7: This is an Ireland as well, so this is a.
P7: combination of everything, this is an average of national figures which probably.
P7: creates yeah Maybe my approach to doing a national level or news for fee is his ability.
P7: and trying to think about some of these parameters actually their their value in terms of.
P7: announced date I don't know and.
P7: yeah some of these new okay pm.
P7: Okay okay okay.
P7: One thing I suppose i'm just curious about is that don't hear it to choose whether and pollution and aerosols just mentioned to I don't know if aerosols are being classified as PM or not.
MODERATOR: No for this version so.
Right.
P7: Okay okay.
P7: Fine yep okay.
P7: Good so the columns that you want to explain the toggle okay so columns I as I can, I can reduce a lot so things like visibility.
P7: Close height.
P7: not really too worried about the rest yeah fine I can remove that.
P7: hold on.
P7: Eric remove them I have removed them it's just there's quite a lot so yeah I want a lot of this information.
P7: it's better to be there, then not to be there, so to speak, i'm curious to see when I download it will the this whole highlighted element feature Probably not.
P7: So it's kind of like as a stage of all function is that you're downloading data, then the the requirement for the being highlighted, maybe it's a way to just identify where to download but.
P7: Currently, this is just data so really I don't think it's necessary perhaps okay and vertically and horizontally so yeah I think of scroll.
P7: Through that yeah so that's point three complete.
P7: For explore the other tabs beside the deal card so i'm curious about these other three time series start there okay so.
P7: zoom hover.
P7: Okay, so there's a lot of information and i'm assuming this is based on the data and the previous.
P7: slide it still includes what i've excluded from the toggle so that's okay and.
P7: directly to the choices made and the data i'm.
P7: just going to read the instructions interactive features, please use those features.
P7: Okay, so a lot of different information.
P7: Value here.
P7: Is value so i'm guessing everything's been normalized.
P7: or.
Not.
P7: minus five to 10.
P7: Maybe after read something I missed.
P7: Variable to D select yes, I can't do that in range later.
P7: Okay, so.
P7: that's more interesting for me to play with turning things off so i've used a ring the slider just to kind of start looking at some items know the scale hasn't changed, so the minus five to 10 has been maintained for the so the six month period governs the scale.
P7: Which know at the moment no I can't see you know it's not I can't I don't believe I can stretch the that aspect anymore, I can stretch the vertical plane.
P7: Which kind of pros and cons and not if I could stretch the vertical I could.
P7: zoom might allow me to do so.
P7: No, it still maintains 10 minus five so you don't get that kind of fit understanding of the of how things are going there.
P7: And lot easier kind of standard.
P7: Okay, so legend i'd like to turn off some of these like the thing items that I wasn't interested in earlier.
P7: cloud visibility climate.
P7: yeah.
P7: quite an extensive menu here to juice on nearly and and I think yeah there's so many really that the time series it's yeah useful for export plot.
P7: But I would want to be able to manipulate the vertical axis if, for example, had a smaller range of time, but I wanted to focus on like like I have right now.
P7: You need that that range can hide information and also i'm not quite sure of when I.
P7: And I said, Mr up what the.
P7: Whole it's been normalized or standardized standardized.
P7: My missing something there i'm not sure if.
MODERATOR: it's expensive.
P7: And so that's it for time series moving on to the box plug.
P7: Okay cool and this is a box plot.
P7: Experience median whiskers extends.
P7: Point five IQ or in the box now I am a bit rusty, why not enough sure, but the 1.5 most met and can think of the logic behind why 1.5 and and.
P7: Maybe it's a slow day and my stats and but so i'm visualization is interactive correct and I can hover zoom etc same kind of functionality as last time don't have the bar across the bottom, but then, oh no it's not necessary, so value here so yeah this is definitely.
P7: The normal life standalone.
P7: standardized yeah.
P7: Think.
P7: and
P7: Again, maybe i'm only interested in some of them So how do I remove some.
P7: As the last leg was really good hideaway like remove that.
P7: yeah some aspects that are just not interested in.
P7: I notice, I can zoom which is great.
P7: And, but I can't select and actually create ago.
P7: When I want.
P7: Okay, again, the scale, then that skill move i'm trying to mature.
P7: Because currently that go one that stretch, more significantly, the zoom really doesn't, allow me to zoom where does it I know it does sorry.
P7: Okay.
P7: yeah no I those.
P7: bit of sensitivity to it, I mean.
P7: And still find yeah hold a turn off somewhat beast.
P7: yeah how do I can't do that i'd like to turn off some of them.
P7: Again it's yeah and lastly porter quite.
P7: select OK, so I can i'll take a pollutant it's more interesting me 2.5 letters PM 25.
MODERATOR: that's I will explain later.
P7: No problem Okay, so this is a distribution with respect to.
P7: When.
P7: speed.
P7: And direction.
P7: For the whole country actually so my logic of picking the whole country doesn't really make it so useful a lot of zeros.
P7: lot of zeros which surprises me.
P7: and
P7: And nothing within the zero to one at.
P7: I did pick daily values that I.
P7: do so that's where the resolution would have an impact.
P7: The daily might not capture the variation across the.
P7: And so okay so there's a wind speed and guessing there's no metric for that i'm guessing it's kilometers per hour.
P7: Typically, though, when speedo would be dealing with meters per second I can't remember in your table if it's meters per second or kph and I typically deal with meters per second it's not the end of the world, but the metric isn't here, which makes me kind of wonder what's going on and.
MODERATOR: You want to hover over the blood.
P7: So I can.
P7: So I can pick individual points and look at individual points.
P7: So much going on in here, though, that I wouldn't even know what to do, maybe my my my my data I picked too much.
P7: But yeah you can so you can see when speed when direction point.
P7: or curious, can you can you download this specific raw information as a or you can just download this PNG file or jpg or PNG is just not the data with it.
P7: would be a nice bonus I guess.
P7: And the colors it I i'm not sure if the colors help or not.
P7: Coming coops and the zoom zoom.
P7: zoom.
P7: zoom is working for me.
P7: up that I just don't.
P7: seem to zoomed in and either no I yeah okay 32 to 42 so i'm actually got a very specific ring yeah not quite sure what i'm doing with this.
P7: doctor as an analysis method.
P7: Good visualization but not sure what i'm going to use it for in my spirit in my area and that's for darn I think it's very yeah so create two new queries Okay, so you need to create two new query so i'm going to be less ambitious with my queries.
P7: Change high probability to possible just curious.
P7: On click Ireland.
P7: and select and cork i'm interested in court, because even higher.
P7: data sources again want to keep my time frame.
P7: Okay 30 30th of September Okay, and when I.
P7: mean i'm just going to select mean this time now i'll keep to Max there's any comparison logic for comparison so there's going to hopefully be faster so absolute q2 q3, so I think we'll just pick a different county the same.
P7: Okay.
P7: let's cue to look up.
P7: yeah okay i'm doing the exact same for changing county in Dublin, because there's a big theater.
P7: And same date range, to see if there's any links between the two.
P7: sleep ice change.
P7: Rather than Cork when she's carry.
P7: Your brain.
P7: see if the two counties of any sort of link.
P7: In results.
P7: and
Okay.
P7: So, with all that information I have my q1 q2 and compare them the comparative cob, so I think yeah I want to compare those two.
P7: Compared to top okay.
P7: So number of groups.
P7: Okay, so it's an up and down at a time, then you there it's so.
P7: Creative.
P7: can be compared yeah so created two and three purposely to compare.
P7: you combine these crews and groups okay so compare pins time.
P7: timeframes event.
P7: location spatial temporal really.
P7: Okay okay.
P7: or different time periods within the same county.
P7: or a specific yeah okay there's a lot of different variations, you could do.
P7: And alone, but you can combine these queries into groups to potentially increase the signal to noise ratio signal to noise ratio is in language i'm already familiar with, I guess, but it would be a term that I would appreciate a.
P7: definition for.
P7: And can appreciate, though the noise side of things, but maybe not the signal.
P7: Besides, the number of groups Jewish yeah selective queries you want to to do explore each environmental variables so click to generate the groups.
P7: And oh so actually I was.
P7: Actually, no I want one group.
P7: and
P7: I don't want to produce something wrong there.
P7: So click to generate groups not good work firsthand what you didn't click property so it's good.
P7: group, one should be good question too.
P7: and
P7: Question three so basically comparing two counties same period.
MODERATOR: Okay, make sure you understand what our group is.
P7: database.
P7: queries.
P7: Yes, for combine the two queries of question correct query to query three into a group.
P7: To increase the signal.
P7: Which to compare oh yeah can I compare county with Harris county.
want.
MODERATOR: To combine combined between groups know between queries.
MODERATOR: I need to make it clear.
P7: Okay.
P7: queries are grouped.
P7: main per unit of time in the time series plot.
P7: Some taking the two counties.
P7: merging them so to reach on almost.
P7: combination.
P7: Constant.
P7: Trading constraints myths belt, I think.
MODERATOR: concatenate.
P7: Oh.
P7: i'm not familiar with concatenate in.
MODERATOR: touch after so you have everything.
Okay.
P7: Now, also never, never came across town.
MODERATOR: i'm going to use another one.
and
P7: Not quite.
P7: Yet so i'm happy with creating a group with to queries.
P7: Unless i'm doing some.
P7: and combining the queries into groups i'm quite combine two counties, to look at a region of the country.
P7: Now so i'm happy with that okay.
P7: I believe I am and.
P7: click to play plot groups yeah so well if it's group it's only one group, though, is that sufficient.
MODERATOR: Go ahead.
P7: um.
P7: fringe groups.
P7: wants to interest.
P7: So I have.
P7: groupon which is combining the two counties or China, close to December and again that can stretch.
P7: it's useful.
P7: Can I do more than one variable.
P7: And maybe that's where I need more than one group.
P7: Okay that's fine OK OK, I can update that I assume I could create the second group yeah.
P7: Let me do love.
P7: To okay keeps going back to that refresh menu which.
P7: and
P7: select a new one, so Actually, I want to compare the country with the two regions so group group two is actually not a group it's well it's a group in itself because it's all of it, so I can achieve it there, but I think i'll get away with it and.
P7: i'm at a better time.
P7: Okay, great PM 2.5.
P7: So allows me to check the two counties supposed to the rest of the country for PM to end sorry I sent out to.
P7: I want this question don't have a.
P7: Specific time period okay.
P7: group one blue representing two counties, the rest, the core countries so card and carry.
P7: As to who's doing much presenting less pollution.
P7: What does that mean, though, in terms of triggers So if you could separate like counties that had no triggers on ones that did have triggers.
P7: You can compare it in that way, perhaps.
P7: And so the box i'm just loving cricket the box and distribution.
P7: box same thing okay so today's game i'm selecting the metric.
P7: In nh menus are not selecting PM 2.5 and then going and looking at it in different ways as automatically.
P7: or automatically it's asking for a manual way to do it, so this This is great point and to its most well okay there's there's there's very significant values here now, this.
P7: Customer what this is called, and this.
MODERATOR: loud.
P7: yeah.
P7: For me, for me, it's like it is preventing the the box plots from being extended to the magnitude that they're at is there a way to switch them off.
MODERATOR: My.
MODERATOR: You might go well.
P7: Okay i'll be interested to be able to turn it off, so the scale, so I could actually look at PM and great that I can hover over it and see all the different key values related to that the box plot there.
P7: that's good.
P7: And lastly, distance.
P7: game and just going to pick on PM because.
P7: personal interest.
P7: So.
P7: Okay.
P7: and
P7: So so comparison distribution.
P7: Okay i'm trying to think what this tells me.
P7: This is significant.
P7: This is Dr Levi us.
P7: Okay yeah to this i'm not too sure if the value of this, because this is basically six months and summer to winter PM 2.5 would really be quite some some yeah this kind of distribution isn't a useful thing in the context of.
pollution.
P7: don't believe things that keep relative humidity or might not when a certain realistic range might be okay, but you're not going to have a normal distribution of a lot of.
P7: The variables that you have, and maybe wins being wind direction, although you might get a kind of a.
P7: Two PICs okay.
P7: So to your visualizations yeah usually the usefulness of the distribution of not seeing it.
P7: OK to.
P7: choose one of the crews to export.
P7: So go to that tab so I have to go back to the tabs and select something to to export.
P7: Something correctly.
P7: and
P7: This is a note here choose.
P7: OK so i'm on that right tab let me scroll.
P7: choose one of the greatest export go to that tab and click the export button from the data table, so I have to go back to the okay so okay at go back to that table click export.
MODERATOR: And what happens with export.
P7: It could be a big file that's fine.
P7: And then I will go to zip download and download.
P7: Now you've done with understanding, where the data is stored, so I just pretend.
i'll click.
P7: Yes, if Donald in local folder name APP files so it's creating a new folder on my drive.
P7: yeah okay it's not going to my download folder.
P7: Okay, and something i'm used to.
P7: It just goes to my downloads folder on my designated download folder.
P7: OK, and then, finally, could you summarize wherever your overall experience and completing these tasks.
P7: yeah generally okay probably a rush to little bit times was my own fault for not reading the instructions and few instructions just need clarity.
P7: And that.
P7: yeah i'm not quite sure about all of the plots like the district normal distribution plot and it's fine you.
P7: Probably great that there is so many variables wondering if the columns versus table.
P7: Traditional to have all of these horizontally, but when there's so many, I wonder, because it's a data to your really.
P7: yeah trying to debate, why do I need to see all this.
P7: F, really, the main objective is to download these one so it's good that you can plot, and so on.
P7: Okay.
P7: and
P7: yeah so.
P7: One thing i'm kind of thinking about is this advent of interest.
P7: And the link because currently have been just looking at environmental and climate data without really appreciating this aspect.
MODERATOR: Within us towards.
P7: So that's the bit that, and you know these dates I looked at them, but.
P7: The joining the dots is not.
P7: Currently there for me so that's a really um.
MODERATOR: Okay, so i'm gonna stop the timer i'm going to stop.
MODERATOR: The remote control.
MODERATOR: And i'm gonna stop the sharing.
MODERATOR: So yeah basically your last input is what i've been told that I missed, so what I improve now is that, instead of giving you agree with all the time, serious i'm going to give you.
MODERATOR: The average from the event and some days back so, for example, if there's an event the 10th of January new 110 dates back your and you have multiple events you're going to manage all of them.
MODERATOR: In if i'm.
MODERATOR: So I was missing this tempura link I was doing it manually but I realized this because I always use this type of data that I have it in mind it's not as useful when combined with clinical data.
MODERATOR: yeah what the end user, you can compare the affiliate sleds against know flares example.
MODERATOR: yeah and you could be your and then i'm going to be actually do the linking.
MODERATOR: So I have the quality ready for the next for the next version.
MODERATOR: Okay, and thank you very much, and when.